a thousand years they have ruled it now
there are only ten a dying race ruled by
a dying Emperor imprisoned within
themselves in a dying land
today once more they gather at the
Crystal as the first Sun climbs to its
peak but this is the way of the Skeksis
as they ravaged the land so do they
learn to draw new life from the Sun
today once more they will replenish
themselves cheat death again through the
power of their source their treasure
their fate and crystal
[Music]
it's probably the hardest thing that
I've ever worked on I'd think of it as
sort of a work of art it's something
hundreds of people created it's a
wonderful texture and depth to this
world it was the most work it was the
most difficult but it was the most fun
it was the most rewarding and of all
projects is the one that I'm the most
proud of
[Music]
everybody is Charlie so Netflix dropped
a new teaser for the Dark Crystal Age of
resistance TV show that it's working on
they haven't announced a premiere date
yet but we know a whole lot about what's
going on with the plot and what the
characters are going to be so we got to
break it down if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos too of course I'll do videos
for these episodes when they drop but as
it's December when I'm posting this
obviously this series is going to drop
during 2019 sometime but right now we
don't know if it's going to be early
2019 or late 2019 so when we get more
updates about that I will do update
videos but just to begin with a quick
overview if you have no idea what's
going on with this series or you barely
remember the original Dark Crystal Jim
Henson film the Jim Henson Company has
been trying to make a Dark Crystal
sequel for the last 12 years finally
they brought the project to Netflix and
they decided to turn it into a TV series
so last year they officially revealed
the project they announced who was
working on it but they didn't really
give us a whole lot of details other
than the time period that it was set
during but as of right now like just
this morning they released the cast and
told us who the characters are so if you
don't remember the original series
there's great conjunctions that happen
once every 1000 years and that's sort of
how they date the events of the movie in
the prehistory of like how the Earth's
qex got onto the planet thraw because
the planet where do this all takes place
is not where they're originally from
there are a bunch of fallen beings from
a much greater race that were banished
there because they couldn't cleanse
their impurities so during their peoples
first great conjunction when all the
planets were in alignment they were
banished to thraw through the power of
the Dark Crystal and they were meant to
live there for the most part they're
functionally immortal so the great
conjunction happens once every thousand
years the second great conjunction was
when they tried to cleanse their
impurities again so that they could
return to their home world but instead
of cleansing the evil from themselves it
actually split each Earth's qex into two
different beings one like the pure good
rational side the other being the
Skeksis the pure it ego-driven side so
they were all about the baser instincts
that's why they had that big long scene
where they were stuffing their faces
during the original Dark Crystal movie
they were meant to represent all the
primal instincts of the
CX original race the whole idea of the
movie is is that during the third great
conjunction another thousand years after
they were split into two halves the
races are united by the gelfling x' so
the prophecy about this great
convergence in the movies says when
single shines the triple Sun what was
sundered and undone shall be whole the
two made one by gelfling hand or else by
none so in the series there are a couple
of core races you have the Earth's qex
which were divided into the Skeksis in
the ARU they have their minions that
they create through the power of the
Dark Crystal
the Garthim those giant crab-like beings
those are just one of those but like I
said they're not originally from the
planet thraw the Gulf links and the pod
Ling's are races that are native to the
planet then you have things like the
land Striders are just creatures that
the gelfling is use but also you have
characters like Aughra who's really
important but she sort of embodies all
races and all genders on the planet so
she's sort of like an amalgam of all the
life-forms including the Skeksis in the
Gulf Ling's so the Dark Crystal age of
resistance TV series picks up before the
events of the movie so I'm guessing that
it's somewhere at the midpoint
they already released the synopsis some
of the information and it teases stuff
that you learn at the beginning of the
Dark Crystal movie so it just reads the
Dark Crystal Age of resistance is based
on Jim Henson's groundbreaking 1982
feature film The Dark Crystal Age of
resistance tells a new epic story set
many years before the events of the
movie and realized using classic
puppetry with cutting edge visual
effects they just lets you know that
it's gonna do it with classic puppetry
not CG so if you're worried about them
bastardizing Jim Henson's work don't
worry this is what its gonna look like
the puppets look slightly more realistic
but they seem pretty faithful to the
original Jim Henson designs then the
description goes on it reads the world
of thraw is dying the crystal of truth
is at the heart of thraw the source of
untold power but it is damaged corrupted
by the evil Skeksis and a sickness
spreads across the land when three
gelfling uncovered the horrific truth
about the power of the Skeksis an
adventure unfolds as the fires of
rebellion are lit and an epic battle for
the planet begins so the thing about
this is that if you've seen the movie
you know that there was a gelfling mass
that happened that eradicated their race
because while the Mystics knew about the
prophecy that they would once be joined
or rejoined with their darker halves the
Skeksis misinterpreted thinking that the
gelfling z' would kill them off and take
their place we know because it's in the
movie that it just means that the ARU
will be combined with the Skeksis to
reform what their original race was so
that they can reassign go back to their
homeworld Netflix is saying that the
series is gonna follow three gelfling
characters named rien Bria indeed but
obviously there are a lot of other big
characters is a really big world with a
really deep mythology so there are a lot
of really famous people playing
characters I don't know exactly how much
they'll be in the series but for the
most part it'll be following these three
Gelf links through every one of the
episodes the leads are Tarun Edgerton
who's playing Rhian on a tailor Joy
playing Bria Nathalie Emmanuel that's
playing deep from Game of Thrones
Donna Kimball is playing Agra remember
during the movie she tells us that she
was there for the original great
division when the Earth's qex were
divided into the Skeksis in the ARU that
was about a thousand years ago so she's
very very long-lived there are a whole
bunch of really famous actors who
they've listed but they haven't said who
they're playing there's Katriona Bal P
Helena bonham-carter Harris Dickenson
Natalie Dormer Eddie Izzard Theo James
Toby Jones Shahzad Latif Gugu mbatha-raw
mark Strong Alicia vikander Mark Hamill
that's right Luke Skywalker is going to
be a character on the Dark Crystal
Age of resistance jason isaacs
keegan-michael key
Simon Pegg and Andy Samberg so like I
said you know most of those really
famous people they haven't said who
they're playing it's the same thing with
the Netflix Witcher TV series they've
announced like a lot of the really main
characters but they haven't said who a
lot of the background people are yet
leave all your video requests in the
comments below they'll probably drop a
proper trailer sometime in the next
couple of months they haven't announced
any kind of timeline for when they're
revealing stuff but while you wait for
everything click here for that new game
of Thrones Season 8 promo and click here
for that new Iron Man Avengers 4 promo
thank you so much for watching everybody
also see you guys tonight
[Music]
you